minus ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five
four
manage and start two
one
[Music]
has cleared the tower she is on her
space with the second human space flight
crew
[Music]
what a launch we are on our way to max q
the first milestone here on its flight
to space
[Music]
you can follow along obviously with the
altimeter at the base of the screen as
well as the speedometer they are gaining
speed on their climb to space we have
confirmed
max q this is when the mat the the
aerodynamic stresses on the vehicle were
at their maximum
[Music]
thank you again everybody for joining us
live for new shepard's second human
flight with audrey powers william
shatner our customers glenda reese and
chris bosshausen on board they are well
on their way to space so far a nominal
flight a clean burn on our blue engine 3
new shepard giving them a beautiful
flight to space this morning
the rocket is climbing towards an
altitude we're aiming just over the
carmen line the internationally
recognized line of space of 100
kilometers that is about 328 thousand
feet
and a gorgeous view down the rocket
and now we've had main engine cut off
the be3 engine has shut off and in just
a moment we're going to separate the
capsule from the booster and at that
point our astronauts will have the
opportunity
to get out of their harnesses and enjoy
the beauties of zero g
let's wait to listen
and there you can see a clean separation
between the capsule and the booster
and there you can see the capsule from
the top of the booster
they are continuing their ascent over
the karman line you'll know when they
hit apogee when the speed hits zero
and there they are over 328 000 feet
over 100 kilometers welcome to space
the newest astronauts on board our crew
capsule
and there they are they have hit
just about hit their apogee
at about 351 000 feet
and while we don't have apogee i can
just imagine jackie they are having the
time of their lives
thank you again everybody for joining us
live from west texas so far a nominal
flight for our second human crew
so exciting jackie to have sent captain
kirk himself william shatner to space i
cannot wait to hear his commentary upon
return as well as our two customers
chris boss housing from australia to all
the fans turning it tuning in from down
under a big shout out to you guys as
well as glenn devries and our very own
audrey powers they are coming back home
the booster of course is going to beat
the capsule back home it is more
aerodynamically shaped of course at the
base of the the capsule it's kind of a
blunt end so it's less aerodynamic what
we're going to see coming up shortly is
at the top of the rocket we have the
ring fin the uh the there's uh some what
we call the pie fins that extend from
the ring fin uh as well as the drag
breaks the the uh the pythons the wedge
fins helps stabilize the vehicle uh like
kind of like the feathers of the back of
an arrow and then
you will also see the drag breaks and as
you mentioned jackie it cuts the
velocity dramatically
there you can see the wedge fins are out
here we see the descent we are going to
expect the be3 engine to re-light just
about 3 600 feet or about 1200 meters
above ground level let's wait for that
now the drag breaks have deployed and
here we come new shepard
[Music]
and touchdown welcome back new shepard
the fourth flight to space and back for
that vehicle provided a beautiful flight
to space for our second human crew
wow that gets me every time we do this
live down here in texas the sonic boom
is so cool drag breaks are folding back
in as have the wedge fins
just looks like you could uh fuel her up
and go again what do you think jackie
and even when you know to expect the
sonic boom it still catches you off
guard every time talk about a rumble a
beautiful sight of our new shepard
rocket there in the west texas desert
but of course
the show is not over the capsule is
descending we are waiting for first the
drogue break excuse me the drogue shoots
to deploy those are very much like the
guide parachutes they will subsequently
be
followed by the uh the main parachutes
that will fully that the full first reef
and then fully inflate and there go the
drogue parachutes
and here come the mains
what a flight
you can already start to hear the cheers
from outside the our our stage here in
west texas
audrey oh yeah
how about that guys how about that guys
that was unlike anything they described
all right
it's four o'clock you're watching sky
news and live scenes from technic texas
and star trek's william shatner makes
history becoming the oldest
to head into space
he's in a rocket built by jeff bezos's
company blue origin you can see the pod
just coming down to lamb let's listen
back in
and capsule touchdown
welcome back the newest astronauts
audrey powers william shatner our
customers glenda freeze and chris
poshausen
what a day for you welcome back